welcome to this video it's a blitz chess
again tobu top tier I played him just
recently I am I forgot about the game
probably probably it wasn't so great ok
i'm playing d5 he played the tory attack
tory against g6 very healthy setup y
term develops naturally and get some
it's a fine position d5 how to how to
develop am not so sure ok try to
fianchetto the special yeah i actually
like right here it looks like white has
some white has a very comfortable
position it's other not so easy to to
make anything tangible out of it yes
yeah i'd like to play e-cigs but the
blunders the queen and don't really want
to play Knight f6
Knight f6 yah he can play 95 it's not so
clear what I'm doing in this position
okay this is very ugly but I don't like
them don't like the look looks of the
other line sir as well
yeah don't like it fit the same the spin
wrong
okay let's let's try something maybe he
grabs the pawn on d5 Bishop d5 cumin
Queen B 5 he can do that but i hope that
i'm getting some compensation for the
poem i'm getting his powerful bishop and
the pawn on d5 makes the night on d to
look a bit silly it's not bad for white
I'm not saying that button it at least
Im disturbs the natural course of the
game
yeah the brocean was just a bad piece
with the idea to play Queen f5 or Bishop
a six or both but yeah not very
attractive this position
yeah it's not nice but not not easy to
play for him I don't think it's so easy
okay let's do that at Bishop a 693 be
sure basics yeah I know it looks like
leave that it's a it's probably
necessary if I go night c4 and it's
playing nazi fire may be decided this
could irritate him so where I'm i have a
tempo him
Quincy 2nite be too seems to work ok so
i need to go down so last night c5 now
yeah that this all didn't help
ok
just push my scent i hear you can play
be three though this is the problem yeah
maybe this is well be three
p 3 also was good efore queen and then
fi therefore this is the only chance
rakta for Rocky III yeah yeah I am wow
what a game guy could resign with the
clear conscience here maybe I should
check yeah I stole the edge file is open
the only miniscule hope
Queen age 6 Bishop to g3 check oops yeah
I know I should resign check still
hoping for a miracle check checkmate
oops this is the funny mate I didn't see
it at all wow this was just crap so
let's let's check this yeah all this I
was a bit of activity but didn't really
did this this was probably just bad I
mean it looks a bit strange what he's
doing but it's not really a problem
there's always light c5 and this pushes
all my pieces back ok this was just
desperation and nothing at all
yeah this is just probably this b6 setup
it's not great yeah this is just an
uncomfortable position for black I mean
this is not nice when prey I mean it's
probably bad but it's just uncomfortable
probably be success is nonsense maybe
Bishop g4 or something just exchanging
this piece then c6 I don't know b6 is
not good yeah this was just bad alright
thanks for watching